I use Google Maps every day.
When I'm navigating the subways,
making dinner reservations,
grabbing a taxi, I
don't have to think
about how it works,
if it's going to work,
whether or not it's accurate.
Using the Google Maps
APIs in a website
means bringing that familiarity
and trust to your users.
It means that while reaching
users across the world,
everybody gets accurate global
data that's familiar to them.
You can learn how to integrate
Google's location services
and maps into your websites
through Udacity and Google's
Maps APIs course.
Learn to create intuitive
map visualizations,
utilize our detailed
places of interest data,
and lead your users
where they need to go.
When you use the
Google Maps APIs,
you bring the reliable and
simple experience of Google
to everything you build.
For more information,
visit udacity.com/google.